(upbeat latin music)
(audience cheering)
- Hello, hello everybody!
I am your host, Diego Luca.
And welcome to Buenas,
Buenas, Buenas Noche!
(audience cheering)
Oh please, please thank you.
Thank you.
We have an amazing
show for you tonight.
But first, did you
hear about this?
Very, very interesting.
Now, apparently Disney
is coming out with a new
musical, yes, it
involves a lot of white
people on skates.
Apparently they're calling it...
hockey.
(laughing)
Ohhhh!
Joke, joke, joke,
joke, joke, joke, joke!
Hey, am I right, please?
Now it's time for one of
our favorite segments.
Singing on motorcycles
in traffic.
Now today's guest is
none other than two time
Academy Award winner,
Daniel Day Lewis.
Let's see how he did!
(audience cheering)
(humming)
Oh my goodness, so good.
I would even say shareable.
I mean, am I right?
(laughs)
Seriously, share it, please.
Share it.
Share it right now.
Click.
On the bottom, click on it.
(ominous music)
Oh, okay!
(audience laughter)
It's time to introduce
our very special friend.
You know him, it is
Kevin the IT guy!
- Hi, hello.
- That accent, I mean,
who can understand it?
Now, Kevin, tell us,
tell the folks at home,
what did you do this weekend?
- Oh, I made my own dinner.
- Oooh, interesting,
what did you have?
- Craisins, asparagus,
and I make my own seltzer.
(audience laughter)
- I get it, I get it, I get it.
You are different from me,
and that is funny to us.
(laughing)
Now after all that
dinner, I think that Kevin
could lose a few calories.
So it's time for Kevin
Learns How To Do Things!
Oh my goodness.
Now with the help of our
lovely and talented Sophia,
(kisses)
today we are going to
teach Kevin how to dance.
Come on out, Kevin.
(audience applause)
- Is this outfit necessary?
- Hey, putting you down
makes me look better, eh!
(audience laughter)
Take it away, Sophia.
- We are going to do
the Bachata today.
Here we go, we go to the right,
- Right.
- And left.
(mumbling)
- Ah, it looks like Kevin
was really feeling it.
Let's take a look at the replay.
(audience laughter)
- You look so stupid!
- But how great was Sophia?
Am I right?
Give her a round of applause.
(audience cheering)
Now as many of you know,
next week I will be on vacation.
- Have a good trip!
- Thank you.
Don't tell my wife.
(laughing)
- No, she knows.
She knows.
But I'm very excited
to announce who's gonna
be filling in for me next week.
Now one of the most
talented comedians I know,
so funny.
She's one of the most--
- No!
(audience jeers)
- No, I don't want that!
- Or, it can be...
any guy.
(audience cheering)
- Any guy!
Any guy!
- Oh man, that was close.
Got you.
That was a lot of fun.
Almost as fun as
our band leader,
BJ Lawrence.
(electronic air horn blows)
(upbeat techno music)
- I already told you,
I'm not in the (bleep) band!
I'm Steve, the
Script Supervisor.
You think I'm the DJ
cause I'm the only
black guy here!
(laughs)
- Well, we're not done
with the fun just yet.
Now throughout the
night, we've been telling
Kevin that he's going
to a cooking show,
when in reality, we're
sending him to meet
notorious drug lord, El Tuco!
(audience cheering)
(chanting)
I lied!
- Have a great trip!
(audience cheering)
- You're going to love him!
Now, tune in next week
when a famous actress
pretends to find me charming
in order to plug her movie.
And until then, Buenas,
Buenas, Buenas, Noches!
(speaking in foreign language)
Alright, get me outta
this fucking place.
Thank you.
(acoustic guitar strums)